welcome back let's just bring you some
breaking news that's just coming in and
that is a Rishi sooner because
officially declared that he's standing
to be leader of the conservative party
and of course the prime minister in the
last minute or so he's just put out a
tweet which says the United Kingdom is a
great country but we Face a profound
economic crisis that's why I am standing
to be leader of the conservative party
and your next prime minister he goes on
to say I want to fix our economy unite
our party and deliver our country let's
just bring in our correspondence in
Westminster early Forza security to tell
us a little bit more about this so Ali
at last we hear from Rishi suno yeah I
mean it's been an extraordinary weekend
we have seen people coming out more than
100 now looks like he's gonna be on the
ballot for Rishi sunak we've seen a
number coming out for Boris Johnson too
but neither man have said if they are
actually they actually want to be the
next prime minister now um after a
weekend of battles fought behind closed
doors Rishi sunak has tweeted you read
part of his tweet there it is um it's
interesting in a way there's no picture
of Russia on this tweet it could not be
more bland in terms of the way it looks
um and we haven't had an on-camera
interview from him either which I think
is quite interesting he seems to have
been behind the scenes waiting to see if
he could get enough support it's pretty
clear he does certainly have the support
to get on the ballot from the
Parliamentary party
um what we don't know yet is how much
support Boris Johnson actually has but
Rishi sunak in his tweet says the United
Kingdom is a great country but we Face a
profound economic crisis and he goes on
to say the choice our party makes now
we'll decide whether the next generation
of British people will have more
opportunities than the last that is why
I'm standing to be your next prime
minister and leader of the conservative
party I want to fix our economy unite
our party and deliver for our country I
served as your Chancellor helping to
steer our economy through the toughest
of times the challenges we face now are
even greater but the opportunities if we
make the right choice are phenomenal
um so clear and the and the statement
goes on I'm asking you for the
opportunity to help fix our problems to
lead our party and Country forwards
towards the next general election so
Rishi sunak is standing is clear
um that if they're we know that there
were talks between the Chance former
Chancellor and former prime minister
yesterday evening
um any sign that Rishi sunak may be
rowing in behind Boris Johnson I think
thwarted by this tweet clear no deal of
such has been made and I think there's
two things he seems to be focusing on in
um his statement there firstly the
economy I think plenty of Rishi sunak
backers feel Vindicated by what has
happened in the last six weeks during
Liz truss's Premiership and secondly he
is talking about Unity the need to unite
behind a single candidate and it is
clear at the moment that he is a person
that will get the most backing from MPS
I think Rishi sunak is hoping
um and it wasn't a particularly sort of
showy announcement it wasn't a
show-stopping video or anything like
that of the sorts we might have seen
over the summer this was a plain
statement from Rishi sunak focusing on
two things one Unity he thinks he's a
person that can get MPS rowing in behind
him can get the most support among the
Parliamentary party and it is pretty
clear bearing in mind people like Steve
Baker this morning who'd formally backed
swella Braverman then Liz truss are now
back English soon that is significant
and we had can we bade knocker Nord
Frost Frost yesterday evening saying
that they wanted Rishi sunak to be the
next prime minister the fact that people
like that are now supporting Richardson
I think is significant and the uh second
thing he's focusing on is the economy I
think he will pitch himself very very
clearly as a person that got it right
over the summer and predicted the
problems that Liz truss's government
faced but of course there are strong
feelings when it comes to Boris Johnson
on both sides and there are those who
passionately believe he is the one that
has the Mandate and he is the one that
can lead the party into another general
election